tom cruise and jamie foxx you remember
both of them started in 2004's
collateral together and back in the day
they had a serious bromance fox we're
trying to heat it up was it this hot
before you got here
look at this
it was a bromance e.t saw on full
display back at the 2004 premiere of
their action film collateral well i'm
sorry
no you're not
both single dads at the time tom's
children thirteen-year-old isabella and
eleven-year-old connor became on-set
friends with fox's ten-year-old daughter
corrine
parenting oh yeah yeah we had the kids
together and everything like that just
you know giving them get them what they
need the tools that they're going to
need to really survive in this world but
just parents you talk about your kids
proud of the kids to be honest with you
he is the most genuine and cool guy and
i told him i said from now on you got a
friend and i'm when i say that i really
mean that but while jamie told us he was
loving life unattached i like being the
bachelor in la and hanging and kicking
in tom said he was looking to settle
down you're our favorite eligible
bachelor well thank you very much
will you ever get married again yeah i'm
i'm the guy who i probably
i like relationships i enjoy the
the complexity and the
intimacy of that nine months later tom
begin dating katie holmes two months
before their 2006 wedding jamie joined
the couple at a football game
they ultimately divorced in 2012 and the
first rumors of a katie and jamie
romance began the following year in
2013. can we say
settle
settle down
[Music]
you